our third panelist who is sued I'm
invested Yan Bashir is a professor of
French and philosophy here at Columbia
University
originally from Senegal he received his
academic training in mathematical logic
and philosophy in France where he went
to the Ecole Normale Superieure
and the Saban where he earned his
doctorate dr. Haditha in philosophy his
fields of reach of research include the
history of logic history philosophy
Islamic philosophy African philosophy
and literature he's published a number
of books including Islam elasticity ver
la fille de la Fidele ET le mouvement
Donovan said Muhammad Iqbal Leopold said
of Sangha Larrick African philosophy and
come on philosophy on Islam his latest
book is Berg song called post-colonial
la la vita dawn upon ceded léopold sédar
Senghor adieu Mohammad Iqbal
in 2009 Basheer was awarded the
prestigious Mohammed and fuzzy prize
from the agile University La
Francophonie he has also held important
government positions in Senegal where
then president Abdou Diouf named him
counsellor for education in culture in
1993 a position which he held through
1999 Bashir is also a member of the
scientific committees of dirigen and the
the coast a poor a development the
lavish national singer shared on a freak
and he sits on UNESCO's Council on the
future Basheer
thank you very much and I will continue
along the lines of what Charles say when
he explained that French matters because
Africa matters or I may have not
actually got exactly that point but I
understand that is what you say so my
main point here would be to say that
French matters because French is indeed
the key that opens the word known as
Francophonie it gives access to the
literary and intellectual productions
from that word the word that indeed
matters but
before I become lyrical about that words
which matters and so on I would like to
let my devil's advocate ask me the
following question well then why it does
Francophonie matter let me try this
answer to my devil's advocate look at
the map I would say of the pao2 francais
and path - as Francophonie is defined
beautifully that's a wonderful
definition now some DPA on the concept
of birth - and if you look at the map if
you put some grid let's say for all the
countries that belong to Francophonie
you end up having some kind of six
continent emerging so I could then to
answer my doubles advocate start
speaking of the richness of the heritage
thus represented its breaths but also
its historical depth
take for example Africa's oral
traditions the literature that we call
sometimes or actually to just point a
word on the pattern of literature French
poet blessed son drivers published in
1921 a book title ontology later
that's not very well known in breath and
reproduction otherwise poetic
productions the purpose of his entourage
in a published in 1921 was to manifest I
called him
la booty Ella croissants plastic day
long African so he was finding an
expression and a celebration in French
of the African languages in which
originally the tales the short stories
linearity is the myth that he had
collected in his anthology were produced
my colleague and friend Visan de Bain
explains in an article soon to be
published the importance of the
different anthologies of the
kind that were published in the early
20th century all of them signaling the
existence of a literature or an orator
that deserves to be known and studied
that indeed matters as lesson rights in
the case of Sandra his ontology is
ontology neg conveys the message that
African oral tradition manifests some
aesthetic ideal that matters and is a
contribution to our Universal heritage
he did by publishing this anthology made
with that particular message the
equivalent of what his friend another
poet Apollinaire did in the field of
aesthetics Guillaume Apollinaire during
the same time was writing many articles
calling for the move of African
artifacts from plus the Trocadero that
ethnological museum to the Louvre
because what he was advocating was the
acknowledgement that these were objects
of us and not just fetishes to be left
for the curiosity of self-proclaimed
ethnologist so he was doing exactly the
same thing with a technology and it is
important because an anthology by its
very nature always conveys the message
that what is being collected there does
matter and I'm sure my mother would be
agreeing with me on this so did sangil's
anthology that our nouvelle cuisine
negative my gosh de langue française
published 27 years later in 1948 the
message of that anthology has been
translated beautifully by jean-paul
Sartre in the preface he gave to that
anthology and which is entitled black
truffles in a way analogous to Sandra
celebrating a little before the richness
and the beauty of African creativity
finding its Express
French shaft was saluting the Epiphany
so to say in a French language truly
appropriated by the black poets of the
anthology what he called the true
revolutionary poetry of our times so to
complete my answer to the devil's
advocate I would say that that
literature which appropriated French as
its medium of expression for African
creativity has now exponentially
developed and this is why indeed French
merits but the devil for its advocate
and never surrenders as you know
especially when that devil takes the
figure of a Kenyan talented Kikuyu
writer just the Mau Mau when boogie
Watchung so boogie would reply well I'm
not denying that African creativity and
creativity from other francophone places
matter I'm just asking why does it have
to be francophone why not beautiful in
general or better Africa for actually
you recognize here in the question I'm
posing or that the devil's advocate is
posing the central argument of movie
watching goes decolonizing the mind and
this conversation am imagining with the
devil's advocate is not imagined at all
I had this conversation with Google
watch on Bob and we were this was the
early 1980s and both of us we were
visiting professors at the University of
I write this was the first time I met
him and we live together in the same
apartment that was given to us by the
University and Google was at the time
planning to write his decolonizing the
mind and he wanted to target especially
say go because Sango represented for him
Francophonie at its word
and Sega's prose is not translated until
now most of it is not translated into
English at all so he wanted me to
translate it from French some of what
Fangoria was saying and it was a
beautiful spectacle I loved to actually
somehow fuel and fan his outrage at what
sangil was saying because anger was
saying I love French when I learned
French it melted under my tongue like
chocolate and boy he was just jumped on
his chair and said he really said that
he really wrote that what a french man
so this is when boogie wrote his
decolonizing the mind targeting so much
anger and if you have the text he thanks
me therefore having translated for him
but not from what my position that was
so Muji decided from then on he had
already decided not to write any fiction
in any other language than his native
key group and he decided from then on
not to write any theory either in each
cookies position is understandable and
it has been followed very little in the
francophone world actually but in the
francophone world I could coat my
compatriot Sher Ali endow who decided as
well never to write a line in French
also or another competitor of mine
Boubacar borescope
who at one point decided to write a
novel in Wolof yamagato
and then he we translated himself into
French and published his French version
of demeanor or title Liberty de la
laguna so here is my response the
response I am Not sure I articulated
that precisely then when I had that
discussion this movie watch on go and
this is why I would like to tell
him now and the question of why French
matters has been asked by Shani under
the figure of the devil's advocate I'm
having a dialogue with saengil by using
those words that seem so outrageous to
him like French being like chocolate and
so on and so forth was just expressing
his own relationship to the French
language he is a poet probably one of
the greatest poet in French language of
the 20th century when you report you
declare your love to the language that
you are actually dealing with every
single day and it is quite normal for
you expressing that type of relationship
to the French language is actually what
every single writer from Francophonie
but also every single writer from France
does we all writers have this kind of
complicated relationship to the language
and this is what's after to come back to
him understood and beautifully expressed
in black bottles what was he saying he
was actually repeating Malhar me and the
notion that literary creation always
happens in this era in this gap that one
at one point feels visibly the language
in which one is green to write and he
wrote that preface at a time when
surrealism was still so important so
what the point he made was that the
black poets of the anthology collected
by single actually lived that a car that
gap better than anyone else
so they were able to achieve what
surrealism was aiming at better than the
surrealist voice themselves so that a
car is what Francophonie is it is not
just something that finds expression in
French it is the
related language that all francophone
writers have used the French language
one aspect of that a car of that
complicated relationship could be for
example what has been called the
tropicalism tropicalism is a word
invented by Congolese writers solid a
vacancy to characterize the particular
style of African writers who would be
appropriating French in that particular
way where they incorporate to the French
language their own peculiarities that he
called a tropicalism it could take the
form of what I call liquid chill until
the writing in between writing in
between two languages and the probably
the best representative of that writing
between two languages would be a model
kuru the high volume writer who use
somehow to speak melanca in French in
his writing a third expression of the
complicated relationship to the language
would be Hoover car Wallace look that I
mentioned earlier who moved away from
France following what he witnessed in
Wanda and then came back to French by we
translating from one of his own novel
into French three different ways of
living that particular a car leaving
that particular complicated relationship
to a language but actually I insist on
one thing this is fully realized somehow
in francophone literature and that is
why francophone literature matters and
is not just a matter of expressing
oneself in some foreign language the way
movie-watching go it's understood it but
in terms of having the type of
complicated relationship each writer has
used the language in which he writes
after all literature is about inventing
your own long visit
the language you write in and this is
what Francophonie does the reason why
French matters is that Francophonie
matters and the reason why Francophonie
matters is that Francophonie is a unique
perspective on one particular type of a
car which is creative and productive and
that we need to know if you agree that
my devil's advocate could consider this
point